NEW YORK CITY.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
WE HAVE TO START WITH SOMETHING
YOU ARE RARELY EVER GOING TO SEE
ON THIS PROGRAM.
WE NEED TO THANK THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA MOB IN THEIR LATEST RAGE
FILLED PSYCHOTIC EFFORT TO SMEAR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY ACCIDENTALLY DID HIS
CAMPAIGN AND FRANKLY THE COUNTRY
A HUGE FAVOR.
IN FACT, THE MEDIA STUMBLED UPON
OUR SERIOUS CREDIBLE CLAIMS OF
CORRUPTION SURROUNDING THE
PRESIDENT'S 2020 OPPONENT.
THAT WOULD BE
SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE.
WE ARE GOING TO GO CHAPTER AND
VERSE.
VERY SLOWLY, YOU WILL UNDERSTAND
IT.
IT GETS A LITTLE COMPLICATED,
BUT WE'VE GOT THE TIMELINE DOWN
PERFECTLY.
THE STORY THEY WANT TO TELL YOU
IN THE MEDIA.
THE REAL CORRUPT DEALINGS, THE
ABUSE OF POWER BY JOE BIDEN, A
MEMBER OF HIS FAMILY, AND HOW
THEY BECAME INCREDIBLY WEALTHY
DURING HIS TIME IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, CASHING IN ON
HIS NAME AND CONTACTS.
WE ARE GOING TO ALSO LAY IT OUT
STEP-BY-STEP SO MAYBE EVEN THE
MEDIA MOB, IF THEY PAY CLOSE
ENOUGH ATTENTION, MAYBE THEY'LL
LEARN SOMETHING FOR ONCE.
IT ALL STARTED LAST WEEK,
REPORTS SURFACED ABOUT THIS
UNNAMED WHISTLE-BLOWER, WHO WAS
ACCUSING PRESIDENT TRUMP OF
MAKING AND ELICIT UNKNOWN
PROMISE TO UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT.
RUSHED TO JUDGMENT AGAIN,
CLAIMING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WELL, HE WANTED UKRAINE TO DIG
UP DIRT ON JOE BIDEN.
WE WITNESS TO THE LEVEL OF
HYSTERIA THAT HE WAS REPORTING.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS NOW FOR OVER
THREE YEARS.
AND NOW THAT THE RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT
COLLUSION FAILED, WELL, THEY ARE
ACCUSING PRESIDENT TRUMP OF
COLLUDING WITH THE UKRAINE.
WE KNOW FROM JOHN SULLIVAN,
UKRAINE ADMITS TO HELPING
HILLARY CLINTON.
BUT THE MEDIA MOB, THEY ONLY
CARE ABOUT INTERFERENCE IN OUR
ELECTIONS IF THEY CAN USE IT TO
BLUDGEON TRUMP.
THEY CARED ABOUT RUSSIA, BUT NOT
THE DOSSIER.
MANY IN THE MEDIA MOB PREDICTING
THIS WILL BE THE END OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THEY BEEN PREDICTING THAT FOR
YEARS.
AS IT TURNS OUT, THOUGH
SO-CALLED "WHISTLE-BLOWER"
WASN'T EVEN IN QUESTION.
WHOOPS.
THIS WAS NOT THE FIRST TO HAVE
INFORMATION.
THIS WAS HEARSAY.
LOOK AT THIS.
EVEN FAKE NEWS CNN BURIED IN A
REPORT THEY DID OVER THE
WEEKEND, THE FOLLOWING LINE.
"THE WHISTLE-BLOWER DIDN'T HAVE
CORRECT KNOWLEDGE OF
COMMUNICATIONS."
WHO KNOWS WHAT THIS PERSON HEAR
HEARD.
MEANWHILE, THE UKRAINIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER, PRESIDENT DENIED THAT
TRUMP PUT PRESSURE ON THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
DENIED IT.
FLAT-OUT WRONG.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," YEP.
NO EXQUISITE OFFERED.
CATHERINE.
>> THE WHISTLE-BLOWER DID NOT
HAVE FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE OF THE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER DID NOT HAVE
DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF THE JULY
PHONE CALL.
THAT MATTERS, BECAUSE TYPICALLY
MULTIPLE U.S. OFFICIALS ARE ON
THE CALL WITH THE PRESIDENT,
INDICATING THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
WAS NOT ONE OF THEM.
AFTER CONSULTING WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THE TOP
LAWYER FOR THE ACTING DIRECTOR
JOE MAGUIRE SAID THE COMPLAINT
WAS NOT STANDARD.
CONGRESSIONAL NOTIFICATION WAS
NOT REQUIRED.
TODAY, SPEAKING TO REPORTERS AT
THE U.N., PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT
ON THE OFFENSIVE.
>> DID YOU TELL THE YEAR
UKRAINIAN LEADER.
>> President Trump: NO I
DIDN'T.
NO IDENTITY.
JOE BIDEN SAID ABOUT HIS SON.
JOE BIDEN, IT'S A VERY DISHONEST
HE DID.
>> A SEPARATE SOURCE TOLD
FOX NEWS THAT IT WEAKENS THE
COMPLAINT, BUT NOT     DOES NOT
NECESSARILY UNDERCUT ALL THE
COMPLAINTS.
>> Sean: NEW YORK CITY MAYOR,
RUDY GIULIANI.
ALL WEIGHING IN TONIGHT'S, ALONG
WITH JOHN SOLOMON AND
PETER SCHWEIZER.
THEY HAVE WRITTEN AND
INVESTIGATED THIS EXTENSIVELY.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR, THE MEDIA'S
FOUR DAY ANTI-TRUMP BINGE WAS
YET ANOTHER FALSE, TOTALLY
MISGUIDED, AND AS USUAL, THEY
GOT IT ALL WRONG MOMENT.
BUT DESPITE SO MUCH TERRIBLE
REPORTING AND MISPLACED
HYSTERIA, WE GOT A BIG THANKS TO
THE MEDIA MOB.
THEY'VE HIGHLIGHTED JOE BIDEN
AND THE COUNTRY OF UKRAINE.
BIDEN'S CONDUCT IS NOW RIGHTLY
IN THE SPOTLIGHT.
THIS MAY BE THE END OF
JOE BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE LEFT KNOWS THAT BIDEN'S
SON IS A PROBLEM FOR HIM.
THIS IS WHY WHEN CLINTON WAS
RUNNING, THESE STORIES FIRST
ORIGINATED BACK ONE
HILLARY CLINTON WAS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT BIDEN DIDN'T GET
INTO THE RACE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO CAME UP WITH
THIS SCHEME.
WANT TO HEAR FROM THAT
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
BUT IT SURE LOOKS LIKE THIS GAME
HAS BACKFIRED.
LIKE I SAID, I THINK THIS IS
PROBABLY THE END OF BIDEN.
>> END OF HIS CAMPAIGN CUSTOMERS
LEGAL I REALLY DO.
>> Sean: THE CONGRESSMAN IS
RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS FAMILY SHOULD
BE VERY WORRIED TONIGHT.
LET'S PAY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION
HERE, BECAUSE HERE IS WHAT WE
KNOW.
THANKS TO THE INVESTIGATIVE WORK
OF REPORTER, JOHN SOLOMON, WE
CAN LOOK OUT A VERY TIMELINE.
WE START IN 2014.
THIS IS WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
APPOINTED HIM TO LEAVE THE
OPERATIONS IN UKRAINE.
APRIL, 2014, BIDEN'S SON SCORED
A LUCRATIVE POSITION ON BOARD I
GAS COMPANY.
ACCORDING TO NUMEROUS REPORTS,
HE HAD ZERO EXPERIENCE IN THE
ENERGY INDUSTRY.
ZERO EXPERIENCE IN THE OIL AND
GAS SECTOR.
ZERO EXPERIENCE IN THE COUNTRY
OF UKRAINE.
BUT THIS GIANT UKRAINIAN OIL AND
GAS COMPANY REPORTEDLY SHELLED
OUT MORE THAN $3 MILLION TOTAL
TO BIDEN'S PRIVATE EQUITY FIRM
DURING THIS TIME.
A YEAR LATER IN NOVEMBER 2015,
JOE BIDEN WAS ADVISED, GET THIS,
BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES," THAT
HIS SON WAS UNDER INVESTIGATION
BY UKRAINE AUTHORITIES, ALL.
AND IN DECEMBER, JOE BIDEN MADE
HIS FIRST REQUEST TO FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR, LEADING AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE OIL
COMPANY THAT HIS SON HUNTER WAS
DOING BUSINESS WITH AND MAKING
HIS SON KIND OF WEALTHY, FILTHY
RICH.
IT LOOKS LIKE A CLASSIC SCHEME
TO ME.
IN MARCH 2016, ACCORDING TO THE
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING,
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN, HE KNEW
THIS PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON AND WAS
ABOUT TO CONDUCT AN INTERVIEW
AND REQUEST THAT HUNTER BIDEN
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT IT WAS
THAT HE WAS DOING WITH THIS
COMPANY THAT HE WAS
INVESTIGATING.
SO WHAT DID THEN, VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN DO?
HE ACTUALLY LEVERAGED
$1 BILLION, YOUR TAX DOLLARS,
USAID, $1 BILLION.
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
AND FORCED HIM TO FIRE THIS
PROSECUTOR.
WE KNOW THIS HAPPENS, BECAUSE
BIDEN COULDN'T HELP BUT BRAG
ABOUT IT ON CAMERA.
WE'VE GOT THE TAPE.
>> WERE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE BILLION DOLLARS.
YOU ARE NOT THE PRESIDENT.
I SAID, I TELL MIKE I'M TELLING
YOU.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
DOLLARS.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE MONEY.
SON
WHY WOULD HE DEMAND THAT A
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR BE FIRED
AND LEVERAGE OUR TAX DOLLARS TO
INSIST ON THE FIRING?
THAT'S A LITTLE ODD, DON'T YOU
THINK?
IT IS U.S. LAW THAT ALL FEDERAL
OFFICIALS AVOID EVEN THE
APPEARANCE OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WHEN THEY ARE
CONDUCTING U.S. FOREIGN POLICY.
CLEARLY, THIS WAS OF NO CONCERN
TO SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JO
SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE,
30330.
APPARENTLY NOT CONCERNING TO THE
MEDIA MOB EITHER.
WE KNOW WHERE THEY STAND ON
THESE THINGS.
THEY ARE NOT DOING THEIR VERY
BEST TO COVER FOR THE AILING
2020 CONTENDER.
IN FACT, AFTER RUNNING WILD WITH
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION HOAX, TWO
AND A HALF PLUS YEARS,
PROPAGANDA, CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
AND A HOAX, THEY HAVEN'T LEARNED
A THING, BECAUSE THE MEDIA MOB
IS NOT TELLING YOU THAT ANY
ACCUSATION OF BIDEN'S WRONGDOING
IS A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
NO, THAT WOULD BE A LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED WITH
THE BIDENS IN UKRAINE?
WILL AFFECT CHECK THE CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
WRONGDOING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
REPEATEDLY SUGGESTED WITHOUT
EVIDENCE THAT JOE BIDEN USED HIS
VP POSITION TO PRESSURE UKRAINE
TO FIRE THE COUNTRY'S TOP
PROSECUTOR.
>> THERE IS NO PROOF WHATSOEVER
THAT JOE BIDEN DID ANYTHING
WRONG OR THAT HUNTER BIDEN DID
ANYTHING WRONG.
IT DOESN'T LOOK RIGHT.
IT DOESN'T LOOK GREAT, BUT
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THERE.
>> THIS COULD END UP BEING LIKE
THE 2020 VERSION.
OH, JOE BIDEN DID SOMETHING
WRONG IN UKRAINE.
>> Sean: ACTUALLY, THE PROOF
IS IN BIDEN'S OWN WORDS THAT HE
CAN'T FIND ANY EVIDENCE THAT HE
KNEW ANYTHING ABOUT OIL, GAS,
ENERGY.
I GUESS THEY DIDN'T SEE THE TAPE
OF BIDEN BRAGGING ABOUT GETTING
THE UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR FIRED
BY LEVERAGING OUR TAX DOLLARS.
AND BY THE WAY, WHERE I GREW UP,
THAT KIND OF SOUNDS LIKE EITHER
YOU DO WHAT I SAY, IT KIND OF
SOUNDS LIKE A BLACK MALE SORT OF
THING, BUT THAT'S WHERE I GREW
UP.
I WANT TO USE THAT PHRASE.
MAYBE THEY JUST DON'T CARE,
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT THEIR
PSYCHOTIC TRUNCATING NARRATIVE.
PETER ASKED BIDEN.
HE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK HIM
A QUESTION ABOUT THIS CONFLICT
IN THE UKRAINE.
THERE WAS ONE ANGRY UNCLE JOE
30330.
HE WAS NOT HAPPY ABOUT HIS
QUESTION.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, HOW MANY
TIMES HAVE YOU EVER SPOKEN TO
YOUR SON AND HIS DEALINGS?
>> Sean: I'VE NEVER SPOKEN TO
MY SON ABOUT THIS.
YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING AT TRUMP.
THE ABUSE OF POWER AND EVERY
ELEMENT OF THE PRESIDENCY TO TRY
TO DO SOMETHING TO SMEAR ME.
EVERYBODY HAS LOOKED AT IT AND
SAID THERE'S NOTHING THERE.
ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS.
I SAY, "BINGO" PETER.
WHY WOULD A VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA BE
DEMANDING THAT SOME UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR BE FIRED OR HE'S
GOING TO TAKE $1 BILLION AND
YOUR TAX DOLLARS HOME WITH HIM
AND YOU GOT SIX HOURS TO DO IT.
WOW.
WHAT BIDEN SAID THERE IS NOT
TRUE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, ALSO, THAT
STATEMENT OF PETER DOOCY IS AN
OUTRIGHT LIE.
HE TOLD THE MAGAZINE THAT HE HAS
IN FACT SPOKEN WITH HIS SON
ABOUT HIS UKRAINIAN BUSINESS
DEALS.
OOPS. HAVING A HARD TIME KEEPING
THE STORY STRAIGHT.
THE LEFT ACCUSES PRESIDENT TRUMP
OF A QUID PRO QUO WITH UKRAINE.
THE LEFT SPENDS IN CIRCLES ABOUT
A MERE ALLEGATION.
BUT THEY BARELY YON WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAYS, "TELL
VLADIMIR THAT I WILL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE ELECTION."
DON'T TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE HAVE IT ON TAPE.
TWO PLUS YEARS, THE LEFT
FREAKING OUT ABOUT TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
IT DIDN'T WORK OUT THAT WAY, DID
IT?
BUT WE ACTUALLY HAVE TAPE OF
COLLUSION, SOMEONE WHO THINKS
HE'S TALKING TO A RUSSIAN AND
HAS DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
THERE HE IS, THE COWARD WHO IS
CAUGHT ON TAPE.
WHAT IS THE NATURE?
DID VLADIMIR SEE THEM?
DOES VLADIMIR HAVE THEM?
>> VLADIMIR SEES PICTURES.
WE GOT THE TAPE.
>> ALSO KNOWN AS A PERSON WITH A
STRANGE REPUTATION.
>> HOW DO YOU SPELL HER NAME?
WAS THE NATURE?
>> WELL, THERE WERE PICTURES OF
TRUMP.
>> SO, PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE OF
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
COMPROMISING MATERIAL?
THEY GO YES, OF COURSE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL BE BACK IN TOUCH WITH YOU
TO OUR STAFF TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO OBTAIN THESE
MATERIALS FOR OUR COMMITTEE AND
FOR THE FBI.
I APPRECIATE YOU REACHING OUT TO
US.
>> Sean: THEY DON'T EXIST.
JUST LIKE THE DOSSIER WAS FULL
OF LIES.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE IN A BED.
WHEN THE FBI FINALLY GOT AROUND
TO VERIFYING THE DIRTY DOSSIER
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR, YEAH,
FROM THE BEGINNING, NONE OF IT
WAS TRUE.
THE LEFT ALSO ACCUSED TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OF WORKING WITH RUSSIA
TO SPREAD MISINFORMATION.
HILLARY'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DIRTY DOSSIER.
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS LIKE DAVID
CORN, LEFT WING HACKS THAT SPIT
ANY PROPAGANDA THAT'S HANDED TOT
ANY PROPAGANDA THAT'S HANDED TOE
ANY PROPAGANDA THAT'S HANDED TO
THEM.
LIKELY DISINFORMATION FROM THE
GET-GO.
LATE IN THE GAME,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" CAUGHT UP
WITH US, FINALLY ADMITTING THAT.
AND ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW
ARTICLE, IN 2016, DNC
CONTRACTORS, THEY ATTEMPTED TO
TRASH TRUMP'S ONE TIME CAMPAIGN
MANAGER.
THE ALSO TRY TO GET THE
UKRAINIAN EMBASSY TO DIG UP DIRT
UKRAINIAN EMBASSY TO DIG UP DIR.
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT THEY WERE IN
IMPROPER EFFORTS.
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTORS EVEN TRIED
TO HAND OVER EVIDENCE TO ENGAGE
IN ELECTION INTERFERENCE WITH A
FOREIGN COUNTRY.
THEY WERE TURNED AWAY BY THE
DOJ.
BY THE WAY, WHILE ELECTION
INTERFERENCE AND THE MOB IT
DOESN'T PARTICULARLY CARE,
WELCOME OF COURSE NOT.
IT'S ONLY ONE TERM FOR SOMETHING
WRONG.
NO DOUBT DEMOCRATS WILL BE SET
UP TO THEIR OLD TRICKS IN 2020.
AFTER ALL, YEAH, JOE 30330 DOES
HAVE SOME VERY CLOSE TIES TO
UKRAINE.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR BIDEN, IF
CONGRESSMAN EAT NUNEZ IS CORRECT
CONGRESSMAN EAT NUNEZ IS CORREC.